well it was certainly a happy Halloween
for Hogwarts Legacy fans because the
devs at Avalanche have confirmed the
third and final unforgivable curse is in
the game that's right imperio also known
as the imperious curse has been
confirmed to be in Hogwarts Legacy and
not only is it confirmed we got some
interesting details about how it will be
used in gameplay we're also going to
touch on why some fans may actually be
disappointed in what we got on the
imperius curse so on Halloween the devs
at Avalanche posted an official Twitter
update it's a mini video which you can
see on your screen now and in this first
shot here at the bottom left we can see
the unforgivable curses are the
strongest known dark spells in existence
also we can see the icon here forming in
the middle of the screen more on the
significance of that icon here in a
second but can we just talk about how
slick that icon is the little hand and
kind of the puppet strings going down
with the head silhouette around it it's
just incredible an absolutely perfect
icon for the imperious curse right there
as it moves forward a little bit more we
see some additional writing that says
place a victim completely under the
Caster's control and then a moment later
over here on the left side again will
you choose to learn imperio and let me
know in the comments below will you
choose to learn imperio during your
first playthrough of Hogwarts like see
not your second not your third not on
your trophy hunt but on your first
playthrough are you gonna go down the
dark path but that's not all we get the
video plays a little bit more we see
imperio pop up on the middle of the
screen then we hear one of the player
characters cast
[Music]
and then this appears on screen which
reads at the top imperio one of three
unforgivable curses and so here's an
explanation of how it's going to be used
the imperious curse temporarily forces
enemies to fight as if they were your
companion while under your control they
take reduced damage from other enemies
to prolong their allegiance to you also
curse is the victim and cursed enemies
take extra damage now if you're having
to read those second two sentences twice
you're not the only one it took me a
couple of times there to figure out
exactly what they were talking about so
while they're under control of the
imperious curse they take reduced damage
but then they also take more damage
because they're cursed it was a little
confusing but I finally think I figured
out exactly what they're talking about
here so it says while under your control
they take reduced damage from other
enemies so while you have them under the
imperius curse they're fighting on your
side they get sort of a shield buff I
guess you could say where they're going
to be a little bit stronger against
those enemies that they're fighting for
you but then the other sentence there
also curses the victim and cursed
enemies take extra damage so the way I
take this part is that these enemies
that are imperious or who knows maybe
other curses could be involved here as
well but if they are deemed cursed if
they have this status effect then they
will actually take extra damage from us
the player now maybe they could have
worded that a little bit better there
but I think that's what they're getting
at so if you could imagine a combat
scenario let's say you imperio an enemy
they're fighting along your side they
have this damage buff while they're
fighting then you clear out all the
enemies you want now you have to take
out that enemy and because they are
cursed you're gonna actually do more
damage to them so you can actually take
them out more quickly when you want to
dispose of them oh my goodness you guys
are gonna be so dark in this game but
not me I'm gonna stay true to the light
gotta stay on the good side no imperious
for me at least on the first playthrough
once we're going for those trophies
though all bets are off okay so at the
beginning of the video I mentioned that
some fans are also a little bit
disappointed in what we got here and
it's really because of this right here
they only talk about combat now I've
personally mentioned a few times on this
very channel here that I think the
imperious curse of all the three I
always thought it was the most likely to
be in and now it's great we know that
all three of them are going to be here
but I always thought it was the most
likely mainly because it has so many
potential gameplay uses so here it seems
they're only talking about combat and
some people are a little bit
disappointed that there's really no
mention of stealth there's no mention of
any other way that we can use the
imperius curse and off the top of my
head I mean I gotta think of so many
different ways that this would be
incredibly useful in certain stealth
scenarios now I will say chandler wood
took to Twitter and he also shared the
post and added this comment happy
Halloween a little treat for the day
with confirmation of imperio and perhaps
some small teases of its effects in
combat so notice he says small teases
there and then specifically its effects
in combat so perhaps there are going to
be other uses of imperio outside of just
combat here I really hope so because I
think that would truly make it even more
appealing even for those like me who
want to play on the good side come on I
mean even Harry Potter had to resort to
using it in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows now one element from the
original series that I'm curious to see
if they Implement at all in the game is
that the imperius curse was actually the
only one that had a direct defense for
it I mean if you had a strong will you
could actually resist the imperius curse
so could we actually encounter some
enemies throughout the game that it will
be even more difficult to imperious them
because they're a particularly
strong-willed now there's another scene
I have to call out and it's from the
Sebastian's Dark Legacy trailer and it's
the scene with the troll I always
thought it was strange that we can see
this troll striking not once but twice
you know maybe if there's one swing at a
troll on an inferious you wouldn't think
too much of it because trolls I mean hey
they're not that smart but the fact that
we see two swings I think it's pretty
clear that this troll is intentionally
attacking the inferiors so that begs the
question are we the one who creates
these in theory or and now I think
possibly the more likely scenario here
is that we the player have actually used
imperio on the try Troll And in that
scene right there he is fighting
alongside us which just makes for some
insane gameplay possibilities and as we
move forward and continue to get more
information on Hogwarts Legacy I am
super curious to see if they have
anything at all for those who do not
want to use the unforgivable curses I've
actually started to hear from more and
more people in the comments like hey
what do they have for us on the good
side those of us who are going to try
and play this on the light side as we
possibly can are there gonna be any fun
spells to use and I certainly think
there will but in the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter there aren't many spells
that are strictly for Dark Art so to
speak there's the three unforgivables
but then even with those I mean
Sebastian talks about there should be
certain circumstances where they
shouldn't be unforgivable now I don't
know whether you agree with that or not
we saw the hero of the main series Harry
Potter use imperio in the last book to
really help him destroy the horcruxes I
mean without that without using imperio
in that moment they very likely do not
get to the horcrux in belatrix's Vault
there are also other spells like sectum
Emperor which aren't going to be in this
game because Snape invented that spell
then you have other things like moles
moldra which was used to cast the dark
mark So I think there will be plenty of
opportunity for them to introduce other
dark spells that don't necessarily fall
under that unforgivable cursed side but
it remains to be seen about the light
what sort of light spells will we be
able to use because that's something
that's not really a thing in the Harry
Potter series at least in terms of light
spells the only thing that comes close
in my mind is expecto patronum because
of the way that spell is cast you have
to think of a very happy memory but even
with that one we see pretty clearly evil
characters like Dolores Umbridge capable
of casting a Patronus charm now
Voldemort may be the most obvious
example of a very powerful wizard on the
evil side who could not cast Patronus
but it's probably not so much that he
couldn't cast it but that he just didn't
need to I mean the Dementors whatever he
did who knows what all was involved in
that process but he was able to control
them somehow without using any kind of
Patronus he also doesn't even have a
full Soul so I'm sure there are all
sorts of theories on that one and from
there I'm reminded yet again of one key
difference that we are seeing in
Hogwarts Legacy that really hasn't been
something we've explored in the mainline
series and that is this ancient magic
this mysterious ability that only our
character seems to possess we'll find
out more about that of course when the
game launches but it's very possible
that we could see different
manifestations of that based on whether
you're good or evil maybe the evil
ancient magic spells would be slightly
different than the good ancient magic
spells now this icon also looks very
reminiscent of the button icon layout
that leaked I guess I shouldn't really
say leaked it was just something we
found in the trailer back in the summer
something that had seemingly went
unnoticed for all this time and then
people found this one little frame where
you could see this right here and this
icon obviously in terms of style fits
perfectly with these now of course
imperio is only one of the three
unforgivable curses if you want to talk
about just how dark we may be able to go
in Hogwarts Legacy check out the video
on the right side of your screen now
where I break that question down as
always thank you all so much much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon